so the democrats have found their new
russia scandal
president trump and the white house are
disputing reports that russian
intelligence officials offered bounties
to taliban lake militants to kill u.s
troops in afghanistan
the white house is pushing back saying
the president vice president were never
briefed about it
there is no consensus within the
intelligence community on these
allegations
and uh in in effect there are dissenting
opinions from some in the intelligence
community with regards to the veracity
of what's being reported
and the veracity of the underlying
allegations continue to be evaluated
we'll just point you back to the
absolutely irresponsible decision of the
new york times to falsely report that he
was briefed on something that he in fact
was not briefed on
but of course democrats are calling for
investigations since speaker pelosi is
hyping a conspiracy theory
this is as bad as it gets and yet the
president will not confront
the russians on this score denies being
briefed whether it is or not his
administration
knows just as i've said to the president
with him all roads lead to putin
he will not he will i don't know what
the russians have on the president
politically personally
financially or whatever it is
jesse how many times are we gonna do
this lucy football trick with the
new york times the washington post and
russian foreign policy stories i mean i
think we're idiots at this point
they do i mean at least things are back
to normal trump's getting accused of
being a russian agent
i guess i guess now like things are
starting to look like they used to so
here's what they do though dan this is a
this is a very well scripted and
orchestrated
intelligence leak to do two things one
when you have some sort of hater in the
intelligence community
that takes a piece of raw unverified
intelligence that no one's even agreed
upon is true
and then they leak it to a new york
times reporter and then
spin it and lie about the fact that the
president's been briefed on it
to make the president look weak against
russia or the fact that
russia has something on him so it
creates this
russian cloud around the president
that's the first thing
the second thing that accomplishes is it
keeps the president tied down in
afghanistan there's a lot of people that
want the united states to stay in
afghanistan the russians
want the united states to stay tied down
in afghanistan
there's a lot of people in um arms
contractors want us to stay there a lot
of ideologues do
there's a lot of people in the foreign
intelligence or the foreign policy
community they want us in afghanistan
the taliban hasn't attacked u.s soldiers
since february since that
so-called truce was signed so that keeps
this post-cold war order together
in a way that people can stay prosperous
and the line is clearly drawn but
capricious why i'm a little confused
it's just another
lie yeah well that's supposed to help
you do that
yeah yeah i need you to unconfuse me for
a moment here so
we you know listen the story appears to
be fake not that the russians may have
paid the taliban we don't know that's
unconfirmed but that president trump was
brief
but where was the equal media outrage
when the
obama administration actually did pay
the death to america iranians i mean
that's not fake news like that actually
happened the media loses credibility
when they do this
well there's plenty of outrage on that i
think from a lot of people um i
certainly hear about it from a lot of
people that i know
that still are very mad about the iran
deal i can't speak to the media
i mean i think the problem you know
frankly is that our institutions
are not trusted and they are broken and
they are broken on both sides of the
aisle and both left and right media
and i think this is just another example
of the cracks that that are
you know it the foundations of our
system uh you know
you know this is obviously incredibly
serious
if there's any truth to what russia has
done
it needs to be verified it needs to be
examined it needs to be
followed up on and we need to act
appropriately as a nation
and treat russia as an adversary because
our troops should never be put in harm's
way
they should not have a bounty on their
head now we but here's the thing we
don't know a hundred percent
we need to not jump to conclusions
whether it's democrats jumping to
conclusions the media jumping to
conclusions
and we also need to talk about
undermining the institutions now you
know we see the white house saying well
the intelligence community
hasn't verified this there's conflicting
statements but we've also seen president
trump previously
not trust the intelligence community so
do we trust the intelligence community
or not and frankly the american public
is consuming all of this and they don't
know what to believe
and and that's why i think we see such a
divided nation
well i think he's nothing to trust he
wasn't briefed according to the story
but dana you haven't been a white house
insider being the face of the white
house at that podium
have you ever seen a volume of
intelligence community leaks
like you've seen under this
administration it's outrageous
well you kind of lose track but i'm
definitely old enough to remember
when the national intelligence estimate
came out around 2007
and there was a footnote in it that
suggested that the united states of
america and the position of the
president of the united states was that
iran was not seeking to try to get a
nuclear weapon which was not true
and it took in fact dan we went
we went to the middle east to meet with
world leaders to explain to them that
that wasn't our position
that's how bad that kind of thing can be
so when i first
saw this story i thought three things
can be true at the same time
number one it's not out of the realm of
possibility that
putin would do this and that i don't
necessarily think it's just about
what's happening in afghanistan we are
in a middle of a proxy war with russia
on a lot of different fronts remember
what happened between the united states
military and the russian soldiers back
in syria a year or so ago
um that was the right thing to do that
president trump ordered that uh
mission second thing that could also be
true is that
there might that this is not verified
that some people
one person heard something another intel
agency is not really sure
that there is conflict conflicting
information and so you get one leak
and then you have this problem as jesse
was pointing out but the third thing
that can be true is that
politically the democrats will pick this
up and run with it they already have
they already have ads out
so all of those things can be true at
the same time and i think that the white
house is right to
do the briefings they had members of
congress there today
uh republican members of congress
tomorrow steny hoyer of the democrat
from maryland he will take a group of
folks to the white house and see if we
can get to the bottom of it but you're
right i mean
obviously the president wasn't briefed
and that is bearing out today
emily your thoughts i see two issues
here
one is whether the president was briefed
or or not and then also the credibility
of single source reporting
there's a difference between full
intelligence products
and also singular operational
intelligence and single source reporting
and if something is put in front of the
president or the nsc that is a finished
intelligence product that means there
were thousands
of analytical manpower and exhaustive
horsepower put into that thing
before it rose to that level and
therefore singular operational or single
single source reports always raise
verification and credibility questions
right including
as dana pointed out who or what might
benefit from purposeful agitation
and to capri's point about the briefing
i think we all have to acknowledge
just as americans that trump does have a
bit of sensitivity obviously with
especially russian intelligence and the
intelligence community
so perhaps he wasn't briefed if they
thought well maybe he won't believe us
anyway or
maybe we'll wait until there's further
verification or a whole host of
potentials
about that as dana pointed out all those
things can be true at one time